the first thing that we want to
understand is that there's only really
four things that could happen
okay the graph can either go up to the
right or down to the right and then it
can either go up to the left or down to
the left okay but what determines
whether the graph goes up to the right
or down to the right okay let's talk
about that first so what determines
whether it's going up to the right or
the down to the right is the leading
coefficient so I'm just gonna abbreviate
here leading coefficient if it's
positive then it's gonna go up to the
right if it's negative it's gonna go
down to the right
okay now you're probably wondering well
why is that Mario well let me see if I
can explain to you see when you look at
a polynomial okay you write it in
descending order from the highest degree
all the way down to the lowest degree so
what happens is this term that has the
largest power of AX that one's gonna
grow the fastest say for example if X is
10 10 cubed is a thousand times 2 is
2,000 but over here if you just subtract
10 and subtract one that's only like
subtracting 11 but this term over here
is 2,000 so you can see like you know if
i graph this as i go to the right 10 i'm
gonna be way up here at like 2000 so
that tells me that if this leading
coefficient is positive i'm going to be
going up to the right now if it's
negative like the second one here 10
cubed is a thousand but then times
negative 2 that's negative 2,000 it's
gonna be going down to the right because
it's a really large negative number
basically when you focus in on this
highest powered term this highest degree
term
you can then ignore all the other terms
because they're not going to be as
influential as X gets larger and larger
meaning as you go to the right end of
the graph or you go to the left end of
the graph okay so now the second part is
we talked about the leading coefficient
that determines the right end behavior
now we want to talk about the left end
behavior and it's very easy what you do
is when you focus in on that highest
powered term okay that highest degree
term it's going to be the first term
when you write it in descending order
you now look at the degree okay so what
the degree tells you is this if it's
even like an even power like 2 4 6 then
you think that the
and behavior is going to be the same if
it's odd then you think it's gonna go
the opposite direction so just remember
even is the same odd is the opposite so
if we were looking at this first one
here y equals 2x cubed we have a
positive leading coefficient so it means
it's gonna go up to the right like this
one or this one but it's an odd degree
so it means it's gonna go the opposite
way to the left it's gonna go down to
the left now you might be wondering well
why is that Mario well if we put in a
negative 10 you see how we get a
negative a thousand times 2 is negative
2,000 see how it's going the a large
negative number so this one is going to
go to this guy right here let's look at
the second one y equals negative 2x
cubed well you can see a negative
leading coefficient so that means it's
going down to the right
odd degree means it's going the opposite
way to the left so that's going to be
this one right here okay so we'll just
draw an arrow there the third one we've
got a leading coefficient that's
positive okay so that means it's going
to go up to the right we have an even
degree so that means it's gonna have the
same end behavior left and right so
that's gonna be this one and the last
one you can see it's a negative leading
coefficient which means it's going to go
down to the right but because it has an
even degree it's gonna also go down to
the left it's going to have the same end
behavior to the left